Bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo episodio di Resident Eagle
io sono Favij e vi auguro buona visione
e buona visione torna in super Oh
fantastico questo volevo vedere
torna in super Madonna dove cazzo son
finito
Beh bello profondità sono tre livelli
sotto la casa ragazzi cioè boh dove
minchia son finito Ecco il Mercante
Spero ci sia anche qua perché sennò è un
casino
Minchia che casino adesso dovrò fare un
disastro per tornare su
questo uno di Assassin's Creed è morto
qua attenzione un atterraggio perfetto
Infatti l'ho visto Occhio che si
svegliano questi Eh
non si è svegliato a posto Ah meno male
qua devo stare attento che ci sono sti
cosi qua sono i cosi per farmi fare
rumore quindi ci sono altri stronzi come
quelli di prima sicuro
che li allarmo se li colpisco però non
so dove sono
Oddio cos'è
altri insetti di merda che è
potreste non rompermi le palle con gli
insetti che già prima erano giganteschi
Cos'è sta roba cos'è Madò occhi verdi
Porca merda porca
Ah siamo già fuori è una lanterna Quella
porca [__] Non vedo niente Comunque
entro stasera non vedo nulla
No Porca [__] lo sapevo magari vattene
a [__] è morto come cazzo è morto è
morto da solo Vabbè non ho fatto niente
Boh vabbè m'ha attaccato è morto e non
attaccatevi sono cazzi vostri poi solo
il tocco della mia mano
Possiede la capacità di uccidere
chiunque dove cazzo è questo è uscito lo
sento Non vedo nulla non si vede un
cazzo È bruttissimo questa parte
totalmente buio
merda
Eccolo
morto
bella per la carabina zaffiro
merda
morto
la Si mi attaccano muoiono ragazzi non
dovete farlo cazzi vostri proprio io più
che dirvelo
Questa è chiusa
perfetto
qua dovremmo essere qua siamo
Qua c'è l'erbetta di prima mi sa Eh
vorrei dire cacate
Allora crea ok
perfetto che giocatore
che non vedo l'ora di incontrare mai mi
è servito così tanto il Mercante ragazzi
devo vendere un'arma non so se vendere
la carabina o la doppietta giusto dubbio
esistenziale Oh che cazzo è ci manca
pure ami il virus Eh lo so sì è una
giornata un po' di merda effettivamente
per Leo Non tutto ciò Quindi tutto
questo ragazzi in tutto questo tutta sto
casino Si sta svolgendo in una notte
insieme al novantesimo episodio si sta
svolgendo tutta una notte Uh c'è il
Mercante lo vedo lo vedo grazie a
Cristian Io vendo il fucile ragazzi
perché troppa roba troppa roba raga
Come si sta qua sotto
Non vedevo l'ora guarda
Benvenuti Cosa c'è in vendita
a striker fucile semiautomatico Ok
l'estensione valigetta ragazzi devo
stendere la valigetta ed è la cosa che
farò adesso avendo tutto sto casino qua
non so se il pompa ha la carabina
ragazzi Io direi a sto punto la carabina
perché insomma il pompa è troppo forte
Thank you che è una Magnum maxata
incredibile estendi valigetta Yes fai
vedere
Oh almeno c'ho un po' più dispa No vabbè
ragazzi prima era terribile e quindi
andiamo avanti comunque non so come
cazzo faccio al mercante ad arrivare da
un posto all'altro così in fretta
situazione delle docce di azoto liquido
ok questa roba
ho schiacciato Porca merda porca Porca
merda io che tocco i pulsanti sali li
tocco a fare io i pulsanti la mia vita
Non l'ho capito ma c'è uno zio qui
Buongiorno Sei vivo No lui
particolarmente non sta bene cioè gli
altri sicuramente lui ancora di più eh
Questo è un ascensore può essere
visitato l'interruttore localizzato in
fondo al laboratorio va bene questa
ascensore e questo interruttore vabbè
andiamo sono sicuro che non ci sarà
nessuno la quale ascensore cioè la quale
l'interruttore sicuro proprio amici
gioco le palle
cos'è cosa cosa chi è perché come mai
come mai io sto per tirare fuori il
fucile a pompa
Ma dove cazzo è dove dov'è
Ma dov'è ma chi è
lo sento ma non lo vedo
Ok a questo è l'interruttore
ascensore è a posto
Ah no ho aperto una porta ottimo
Ok ok Ahia porca [__]
Tutto a posto a posto Sono tutto tutto
ok era un Tentacolo ma qua succede
spesso un gioco di tentacoli
perfetto È un hentai Ecco l'interruttore
incredibile ma è in tutto ciò sto tizio
chi cazzo è
corrente riprese mo' scende il gioco le
palle che scende
è sceso
Ah Alien isolation e ditelo porcaputtana
che schifo
Ho colpito l'ho colpito non so se lo
posso uccidere lo posso uccidere No non
lo uccido vado là non so se posso
ucciderlo Oh no non è vero
mi incula tutta la vita
non è ancora abbastanza
non mi ha ucciso non mi ha beccato vai
vai vai corri corri corri corri
Madonna che brutto
Eh ho capito che sta arrivando ce lo
sapevo dell'ascensore
No ragazzi
terrificanti Eccolo
non lo faccio fuori perché secondo me
non lo posso uccidere
voi non lo so eh cioè io qua non vado a
logica poi non ne ho la più pallida idea
attenzione Schiaccia il tasto nel dubbio
porca la merda porca Porca schiaccialo
Potato
lo schiaccio più vabbè entra qui Raga
non so se lo posso far fuori questo non
ho idea Minchia quanto tempo ci mette
sta ascensore del cazzo
e dove vado
[Musica]
Ciao
porca [__] porca
Ma che culo
ah lo posso colpire Eh vabbè minchia
cazzo sei in Tekken ma lo posso uccidere
No secondo me non lo posso far fuori
raga quanto tempo sto ascensore del
cazzo mi sa che è sceso lo zio Ah c'è
un'altra stanza qua Bene bene Buono a
sapersi può spaccare qua
Minchia che botta che male Ma che t'ha
fatto Ma che t'ha fatto ma che t'ho
fatto io che male ma va' incredibile C'è
sciolta sto titolo
Grazie di avermi dato munizioni che
probabilmente non posso usare io sto
dando per scontato che non lo posso
uccidere poi non lo so Eh ragazzi Magari
sì
dai
Vai entra qua dentro
Mi sa che questa volta non l'ho [__]
anzi ma [__] lui
minchia lo schivato non so come Guarda
quanto cazzo ci sta mettendo sta merda
io non ho parole
sono morto probabilmente sono morto
meno che non riesca a fare una schivata
di quelle secolari posso provare a
schivare ma non so quanto io riesca vai
Ci provo io no è arrivato l'ascensore
bene
[Musica]
non lo vedo più dove cazzo siamo aiuto
Vabbè l'ho schivato Non ci credo non ci
posso credere Vai vai corri
corri
Ahia veramente
Ma vai quanto tempo
No veramente raga
Madonna
Mamma mia pure
Ecco Ci mancava solo questo Eh ragazzi
la tua sofferenza finire come quella
della nostra nuova figlia che si è unita
noi in comunione ma questa è la
comunione Porca [__] pensa la cresima
com'è
questo è
Sì sì però Sei brutto in culo nessuno ti
ha mai detto
fai da sette anime tanto c'è uno scettro
di tentacoli il suo che è bruttissima Ah
stava dando ordini a qualcuno
Che cazzo è
chi cazzo è quello era il suo era il suo
mentore quello che allenava Lion quello
che si vede nella cinematica iniziale o
sbaglio hanno reclutato lui
Ma questo che cazzo ci fa qua
un buon prezzo Ma sei stronzo Cos'è un
Power Bank
cosa ci fa qua Questo qui cosa ci fa
questo questo vedendo ragazzi Cosa sto
vedendo Santo Iddio bravo che ti che
spunti a cazzo mi fa piacere questa cosa
Ti senti meglio
sì Pare che funzioni Ah quella roba lì è
l'antidoto
Ah ok
svaniranno
cioè devo continuare a iniettarmi roba
tutta la vita
in tal caso
abbiamo che cosa
fare comunque la sua giacca è
incredibile
così ti fai male
era la mia Lancia Ma mi poteva capitare
un compagno normale ragazzi Vi prego
perché mi aiuti però Ah quindi adesso mi
segue Vabbè comunque io non mi spiegherò
mai sto tizio come faccia a essere
ovunque nel mondo ma di uno che lavorava
per l'ambrella Sì a parte quello Questo
è il pezzo allora me lo ricordavo c'era
un pezzo con le miniere non sono io
stupido la TNT io non gli sparerei a
quel coso poi non so voi
una piccola chiave comune che cazzo devo
fare da quando è un piccolo ficcarci
l'esplosivo
lui mi aiuta quando Combatto contro la
gente Spero di sì adesso scopriamo
subito tutto questo è sotto la casa Eh
ragazzi Volevo solo ricordarvi questo
c'è una casa che sotto a questo
Sì sì quello che dici tu aiuto
Giovanni fai qualcosa perché non non è
che posso fa tutto io io ve lo dico già
funziona
Vai
c'è una con la motosega No perché sento
la motosega sono una motosega ragazzi eh
C'è uno Eccolo lì lo stronzo malederci
mancava questo mi mancava proprio uno
con la motosega proprio non vedevo l'ora
di rivederlo
cadi quella puttanazza occhio
è cascato
perfetto l'ho ucciso Non è vero cazzate
cazzate cazzate cazzate in immonde e
Paolo aiuto
Ok ok
un cazzo OK esploso fratello
merda ho mancato tutto
e che cado Dove cazzo sei uscita da dove
cazzo sei uscita aiuto e vabbè che male
allora facciamo una roba ascoltate uno
stronzo e sono io lo stronzo Facciamo
così guarda io ho le granate io userei
queste te la regalo perfetto
ha funzionato Ah perché ho colpito anche
il tizio mi dispiace Scusa zio non
volevo ma qua non posso fare distinzioni
c'è casino Quindi
Madonna che botta gli ha dato
quell'altro Meno male che li ammazzo
stai ammazzando i tuoi zio non se sei
accorto ma si può andare di qua Secondo
me comunque mi conviene farlo fuori così
aspetta fratello
merda
[Musica]
lo posso contrastare comunque un L1
attenzione
è morto
e muori è morto l'ho fatto fuori non ci
credo
mi ha dato uno smeraldo Vabbè dai non
male
Ok perfetto bravissimo
Paolo quello no no Almeno porca di
quella [__] che male
via via via via via che quello esplode
almeno è più utile 10 li sto qua quanta
gente così quanta
penetrazione Granata progettazione Ciao
che cazzo stai facendo e che cazzo sto
facendo secondo te che sto facendo
Ok
allora piano piano piano piano piano
piano piano piano piano piano piano
piano
devi darmi una mano frate
pure tu
Ok ok
Porca [__] che male Eh non l'ho
colpita come te non ci credo Bravo
spara spara spara spara spara spara
spara spara spara
Oh ma ce la fai Ah ecco è morta morta
è morta ed uno Zaffiro in tutto sto
casino Va bene io non ho idea di dove di
dove io stia andando ma se mi muore il
tipo mi finisce Cioè lui non può morire
teoricamente tiriamo la leva
teoricamente qualcosa dovrebbe fare
aggira tutto Ah si è abbassato il ponte
tutto sto casino per far abbassare un
ponte va bene Sono d'accordo sono più
d'accordo
Granata potente ho trovato è una granata
più forte
ci sono le grafiche questa anche me la
tengo Guarda non la uso a cazzo tanto
perché ovviamente normali sono già forti
di loro
si può c'ho paura che arrivi gente in
una maniera incredibile
Porca [__] No
Perfetto Ok
vai vai vai giovane uh
Ok
A posto a posto no Madonna che cazzo è
messo male e che devo fare io
granate li tiravo le granate alla porta
facevo prima Mamma mia che fastidio sta
gente Quanti sono poi sono veramente
tanti come cazzo ci fate qua sotto tutti
quanti chi cazzo Me l'ha detto Vieni qua
oh via
e vai a controllare Sì vai lì
non ci credo
dai Non ci voglio credere ma sul serio
Che ne so io mica vado a fare esplodere
miniere nel tempo libero Cioè ma scusami
Ok Fammi mettere questo qua [__]
va
prossima volta aperti ma dimmi Teo Ma
come poteva accorgermi di sta cosa ma
Scusatemi te la cavi davvero bene
sicuro di essere soltanto un ricercatore
sono solo un tipo qualunque anche se
Tutte le donne mi desiderano No perché
risulteresti molto più simpatico però sa
questo su Tinder che foto Mo vi faccio
Tinder e metto le sue foto Vediamo che
succede per curiosità attenzione
Prevedo boss Fight la Prevedo
ci viene anche tu però eh zio mica la
faccio io
e figurati
[__] come mi sono cagato
[__] come mi sono cagato Ecco meno
male almeno c'è anche lui Sparagli Fra
te bravo
questo è grosso Raga raga
due due
Ma che cazzo ma cosa ci fanno questi qua
sotto per No vabbè non ci credo e adesso
non so bene cosa dovrei farci contro
questi Però penso che
cosa cosa è questo Lascialo a me devo fa
questa roba gli sparo normale Frate io
ti sparo poi tu vedi morire
Madonna di Dio ma che cazzo sono enormi
raga
Ok hai sputato lo zio dietro va bene
Forse posso magnumarlo questo Eh però
non lo faccio perché
Madonna ma è terribile è terribile ti
puoi piegare dice perché io non so se
questo qua lo puoi far fuori anche solo
sparandogli a sta cosa perché poi dopo
un po' Si accovacciano esatto Adesso
papà non lo fa lo fa Perfetto allora ti
lascio con quell'altro io faccio questo
ok che non so sebbene Sì i colpi della
Magnum servono per questo qua secondo me
non servono queste parole più che altro
usare quello la carabina forse questo sì
ah gli è tornato dentro Allora devo fa
così
Madonna come lo schivato Non lo so c'è
un altro qui Ma che cazzo fai tu come
mai non l'hai fatto fuori e devi fa' se
io tengo questo tu tieni l'altro Però
fallo No vabbè Ragazzi ma è inutile la
merda così [__] Scusami Ciao vai a
fare qualcosa
e dolore Ho colpito vedi che basta
questo eh teoricamente basta Questo
Com'è che si approccia perfetto
Ok vai vai vai vai vai vai vai
eh bravissimo Allora teoricamente un
altro paio di colpi ed è fuori eh
aspetta che
in faccia devi farmi in faccia due è
morto l'ho seccato Non so come ma l'ho
seccato
manca l'altro non ho più colpi del
fucile a pompa però
Questo è un po' più cazzo è infatti
perché è bello
corazzato questo capito come cazzo lo
sai Porca [__] che è
come lo secco
E io che va bene
non è infatti che devo fare fai qualcosa
Porca [__]
male Mi sono fatto male Non so se non
siete accorti mi sono fatto veramente
molto male non ho più Cure ottimale
e posso anche unire queste due però devo
fare attenzione devo stare Attenzione
sto Attenzione ragazzi bravo fai
qualcosa
dove l'hai trovato quel coso Vai
tirarglielo Bravo fallo saltare fallo
saltare
Ma devi accenderlo
lo devi accendere Ah no devo sparargli
io ok
Eh ho capito spara Porca [__] porco Dio
non lo prendo È impossibile che cazzo
non lo posso prendere non lo posso
prendere è impossibile
impostare Fermo
Oh [__] va' grandioso un cazzo
vai Vai veloce veloce
Secondo me io faccio molto prima a
sparargli con la carabina a fare quando
esce invece che andarci di coltello Sono
quasi sicuro che per me non serve un
cazzo fai così gliene devi mettere
un'altra adesso dobbiamo rifare cioè si
può fare così anche normale Meno male
però aspetta Vai
perfetto la mia Mira del cazzo
niente io non lo posso colpire
Ok due ore guarda quasi quasi mi
continua a sparare con la carabina
Invece così
era molto faceva molto prima anche con
l'altro secondo me Madonna mia che ansia
ma che ansia terribile c'è qualcosa
nell'occhio zio non so se te ne sei
accorto
ma mi hanno droppato qualcosa Uh un
Berillo e l'altro un Birillo questo mi
ha droppato niente Ma [__] è stato
ho bisogno di una camomilla per
riprendermi cioè due due giganti è
impossibile lui se
bene grazie
[Musica]
per ringraziarlo di tutta sta Sì sì
certo io mi ha fatto un cazzo però vabbè
no non è vero
custodite dentro antichi depositi di
acqua veramente
Ecco allora torna tutto ecco Perché
esistono le miniere l'unica roba che non
mi convince è il fucile a pompa questo
perché secondo me potrei farne potrei
fare di meglio potrei trovare uno
migliore per salire su questa cosa un
carrello
c'è un carrello la vedo c'è una parte
che mi ricordo di sto gioco dove c'era
un carrello era terrificante Ed è
proprio questa ragazzi Vabbè dai
facciamolo facciamolo
ragazzi
non sei acculturato Se lo fai Smettila
Oh ho i proiettili infiniti per la Red
ragazzi eh mi ha dato praticamente
infiniti quindi ci sarà un botto di
gente
Let's go secondo me c'è la divertirsi
qua ragazzi perché coi proiettili
infiniti vuol dire che posso sparare a
chiunque ma c'ho solo questa
devo pure inclinarmi Minchia ci manca
solo
adesso mi spunterà la Madonna che non si
sa come diventerà Mario Kart sto gioco
ok
altrimenti ci schiattiamo perfetto Non
so come ho fatto ragazzi Non chiedetemi
però la Red non è proprio ci mette un
botto a caricarsi quindi non so se è il
massimo perché mi ha preso la mia
pistola standard
non mi ha preso una pistola Random
attenzione
ok
Porca [__] che male
Ah c'ha pure la vita il carrello Lo
Stregone attento [__] attenzione
ma è difficilissimo raga Eh ma è un
casino
con la Red ragazzi è un casino con la
rete è un casino Oh Madonna di Dio
Vabbè per le frecce si rompe ma non per
queste cacate va bene
Oh merda
eh raga Sono nella cacca
a posto mi sono salvato il culo non so
come ho solo più una vita
mi ha mancato non so come Che culo che
culo
Sono ancora vivo
io ci credo
si sono stupidi cazzo Viaggiate con
qualcosa esplosivo
Beh è andata bene C'ho ancora un se mi
sputano sono morto però quello è un
altro dettaglio Quindi speriamo finisca
presto sta roba Tanto saltino no
Minchia
è finita è finita Che culo ce l'ho fatta
ce la fa con destrezza con audacia e con
un gran Bucio de culo
ma ci sono altri carrelli Ah non c'è
nessuno ho sentito qualcuno ho sentito
versi sento versi Che cazzo sono Eccoli
ok
No merda
a posto che comunque Ragazzi è da un po'
che non esci in mezzo alle palle Quindi
niente male
non preoccuparmi di quella lì Minchia mi
è tutta un'altra roba dobbiamo usare un
altro No non ci credo un altro carrello
Vabbè proviamoci Vamos
bene
È tutto un carrello sto parte di gioco
va bene
non so se fidarmi di quello che stiamo
facendo ma nel dubbio
Ma se volevo giocare a Gran Turismo
giocava Gran Turismo io potete fare
quelle cazzo che volete voi
ne sento Porca [__]
perché cazzo devo fare io qua
come faccio a farlo fuori quello lì con
la motosega come lo secco non lo posso
seccare Questi li devo far fuori solo
con gli esplosivi ragazzi se no
Vabbè teoricamente anche no
Ok [__] stronzo Oh
Ok a posto dai mi ha colpito una volta
so due volte poteva andare peggio
ma ma sei stronzo Allora
dove cazzo siamo
Minchia solo prendeva ah ah
Porca [__] c'è un esplosivo se lo
prendevo Era incredibile Ok io non posso
fa fuori tutti quelli con la motosega
comunque eh
mi vuoi dare una mano tu brutto Ah se
colpisce lo colpisco non mi colpisce Ah
e dillo su Subito che ne so Io bene
molto bene anzi di carica veloce però
veloce veloce veloce veloce veloce
veloce perfetto piano mentre mi colpisce
eh
Ok
va bene
[Musica]
merda
Sto ricaricando veloce
attaccami Ok a posto di nuovo
c'è di nuovo Perfetto ciao arrivederci
basta niente male ragazzi niente male
intanto andare peggio andare peggio vai
vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai
vai vai
Madonna che
Porca [__]
fratello già sto sparando vuoi almeno
pensarci tu a quello che cazzo è
È qui che hanno riesumato gli insetti
Minchia pure Ah quelli quelle merde che
ci sono al piano di sopra nella sala
grande ecco
fate voi Eh ragazzi Io non ne voglio
sapere
Mi sa che siete nella merda però tanto è
svenuto
Ciao ragazzi
Ma dove salta dove
sì Vabbè Vabbè
Ragazzi sto male
Ma che cazzo sto vedendo raga Cosa sto
vedendo
figo Beh è stato divertente Comunque non
possiamo dire il contrario Beh Luis
Seguimi fai le cose porca [__] ogni
volta posso fare Ci mancava questa Eh
l'avevo detto io
forza facendo il giro Ah lì Dici Vabbè
non mi fate incazzare Vai andiamo avanti
non comunque riesce anche così sto gioco
non me le spiego Eh ormai questo gioco
in generale in tutti i giochi cioè un
punto facilmente raggiungibile No non lo
puoi raggiungere Mi spiace che tanto
c'hanno le scale perché loro lo sapevano
che sarebbe crollato sto punto va bene
aveva senso sti barili ci sarà la
Madonna adesso la partita non è vero Non
l'avevo visto chi cazzo è
se li preferisco perché erisciotto però
sono tanti quello è il problema
merda
Ma dai ok
perfetto perfetto
a posto Mi sa che la Red nuova è stata
la miglior scelta di sto gioco
Sì sì non ti preoccupare Oh
Porca [__] Ragazzi ma veramente non
li io non li vedo non si vedono non si
vedono Minchia ma è incredibile guarda
ma incredibile Cioè questo non li vedo
sono invisibili
Minchia ma assurda sta cosa raga è morto
adesso è morto è orribile Cioè io non
posso non vederli guarda
cioè io di tutti quelli che mi sono
spuntati finora non ne ho visto neanche
uno Cioè mi sono tutti completamente
usciti dal nulla per me Minchia oh mo ci
sto attento ragazzi veramente Ok
Eccolo Adesso lo vedo [__]
Minchia il primo che ho visto raga è un
evento pazzesca sta roba qua Ci sarà
qualcuno che dice cose esplosivo Anzi lo
faccio già saltare Ciao fratello
e siamo arrivati teoricamente
chi è porca [__]
ok
Boh
perfetto è morto
bene raga bene bene bene bene bene bene
bene Ti conviene farli fuori quando si
appoggiano perché almeno riesco a
lootare quello che mi fa mi danno sono
incazzati per caso no Mi hai fregato un
cazzo a questi qua Vieni fratello
ok
ma è andata meglio del previsto Eh
pensavo peggio Madonna quanti colpi ho
della Magnum potrei shottare un boss
Secondo me
Sono stremato Meno male che la
tecnologia ci assiste Sì sì non si
spaccherà tra mica un secondo questo
non ci conosci neanche
te l'ho detto
mi fa sentire meglio Dimmi la verità per
una volta lo si è illuminato
lavoravo per loro
ecco la verità aiutare voi due non è
abbastanza per redimermi lo so però
non voglio che ci siano altre vittime lo
si illuminando se sarebbero quegli altri
Vedi di fare sul serio
parole dure per uno scudiero
per uno mi dice che sono un cavaliere
l'altro scudiero Oh ma ragazzi uno mi
dice Sancho Panza
sono pronto a respirare aria fresca
se siamo arrivati fin qui vuol dire che
siamo quasi
quasi cosa ok
Che cazzo è
lui ma che è
sto figlio di [__] Ma chi è Da quanto
tempo non ci si vede ma lo sapevo che
era lui quello che aveva allenato Lion
Ma che cazzo
ok Vabbè che ci fa qua No scusa
Ah ecco
lo uccido merda L'ha fatto fuori sul
serio ma non è morto dai è facile
non è morto
Tu sei sveglio Porca [__]
I coltelli sono più
veloci
ma veramente ma Ragazzi ma questo qua
che cazzo ci fa qua non ho capito il
senso
Porca [__] che male Eh vabbè Minchia ma
è spider-man certo è una boss Fight
quindi odore
Ma io userei le armi comunque altro che
coltello
devo usare solo le botte non posso usare
le armi normali
non funziona un cazzo la parata non va
lo sto schiacciandoli
Ok perfetto
altro coltellate in faccia
bello Madonna questo schivato fortissimo
[Musica]
Ok
Ahia cazzo [__]
Ahia che male
a schivare me la cavo a parlare un po'
meno però vabbè
Madonna che botte
picchiai un cartone nei coccige
quello che è successo
Perché devo schiacciare al momento
giusto non lo so perché se io tengo
premuto le uno non para Cioè non so che
cazzo però che non duri molto sta Butter
perché sono già ho già finito l'erba ok
No no schivato ve lo giuro ve lo giuro
che l'avevo schivato che male
bene apprese comunque di coltellate lo
zio eh
è morto sono morto io
ancora vivo
grazie a craist
secondo me c'è qualcosa dentro ma si
trasforma malissimo può essere no non si
è trasformato se n'è andato
Eh questo è ridotto male Secondo me è
una bella coltellatina
una grande perdita per tutte le donne
Madonna che palle questa storia non
parlare
la chiave del mio laboratorio poi vi
Rimuovi qui
c'è l'accendino nell'ambrella Tra
l'altro Bellissimo lo voglio anch'io non
fumo Ma vabbè sopra averlo fighissimo
[Musica]
Sai
ho avuto una vita di merda Penso che
Lion non sia tanto diverso
le persone possono cambiare
piano citazione di Rocky
non so No no Minchia è morto davvero
raga Porca [__] era l'unico che faceva
qualcosa l'unico compagno che ho avuto
che ha fatto qualcosa no
Poirino povero Luis e quindi ragazzi
anche questo episodio aggiunge al
termine Mi spiace perché ogni volta che
finisce vorrei continuare mettendone
altri 65 Ma stanno uscendo tutti i
giorni Quindi direi che è via lamentate
Spero vi stia piacendo ragazzi lasciate
un mi piace un commento Fatemi sapere
cosa ne pensate del Gameplay e noi ci
vediamo anzi scrive nel canale noi ci
vediamo al prossimo episodio Beh ragazzi